[Música]
y hablamos de salud en directo américa
de france 24 conmigo por supuesto en el
estudio más romeros a la bienvenida a
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a viajar
vamos a volver a bajar al gigante
asiático para hablar de la crisis
sanitaria que atraviesa esto porque por
cuenta por supuesto de la pandemia de
kobe 19 porque mientras sigue el
confinamiento en shanghai beijing sigue
en el arma por los contagios de la
pandemia exacto raúl le vamos a repasar
brevemente las cifras para saber de qué
estamos hablando sobre todo en estas dos
grandes ciudades actualmente china tiene
26 mil 776 casos activos de kobe 19 en
el país y en shanghai en esta gran
ciudad donde viven más de 25 millones de
habitantes desde finales de marzo se han
contado 238 muertes para entender pues
un poco la proporción en verdad en más
de un mes es poco no la cifra de muertes
total en china desde inicio de la
pandemia además ya son cuatro mil
878 pero vamos a profundizar un poco más
en la cifra de contagios de aquí en este
gráfico ven el promedio de casos diarios
de kobe 19 respecto a la población vemos
como en china estamos alrededor de los
20 a 32 por cada millón
y para comparar y para contextualizar
eeuu que está en 157 como a 22 casos de
kobe 19 por contagios perdón por millón
de habitantes estas cifras pues para
unos pueden ser indicador de la
desproporcionalidad de china en la
respuesta a la pandemia para otros será
la irresponsabilidad de eeuu y puerta
pues ahí le dejamos a la gente para ver
qué piensa sobre esto pero como está
siendo la respuesta de las autoridades
frente a este nivel de contagios mar
pues mientras sigue el confinamiento en
el shanghai precisamente desde beijing
en nuestro corresponsal adrián foncillas
nos explicaba qué medidas se están
tomando para tratar de evitar un
confinamiento como en el de la otra
ciudad
19 de los 21 millones de pequineses
están sometiendo esta semana a tres
rondas de test con el objetivo de
averiguar cuál es el alcance del brote
que fue detectado el viernes había miedo
a que estos tests masivos hicieran
emerger un altísimo número de contagios
pero hoy se han formado apenas 34 para
un total de 113 son cifras bajas que por
ahora alejan la posibilidad del
confinamiento en la ciudad hay bastante
más tranquilidad hoy que durante el fin
de semana ya no hay compras compulsivas
y las estanterías de los supermercados
han recuperado su esplendor habitual la
rápida reacción de las autoridades de
beijing busca controlar el brote en sus
inicios y así evitar confinamientos tan
largos y dolorosos como el de shanghai
beijing sólo ha necesitado 20 casos para
ordenar los tres masivos cuando se
necesitó más de un millar de casos
diarios la consecuencia es que shanghai
camina y hace a su quinta semana de
encierro y hoy anunciaba otras 48
muertes también hay noticias positivas
hoy es el cuarto día consecutivo en el
que han bajado los contagios en shanghai
las autoridades han anunciado que
relajará las restricciones de
movimientos en aquellos distritos donde
no se han registrado contagios
y avanzábamos que la manera de registrar
los casos en china es como un poco
diferente cómo se cuentan entonces marc
y cómo se registran los casos de kobe 19
en el gigante asiático más allá de si es
una buena o mala manera vamos a dar esta
información que en realidad es básica
para poder hablar de estos contagios y
entender no de que man entonces estamos
hablando primero de todo en el caso de
china se separan el conteo de los casos
de contagios de lo que se consideran
casos asintomáticos aquí están viendo
que en el último reporte de diarios y
dijeron que había mil 818 contagios por
kobe 19 frente a 12 mil 474 casos
asintomáticos como ven la proporción es
muy distinta y si eso va sucediendo cada
día pues se acumula una diferencia
grande importante también decir que
cuando una persona empieza a presentar
síntomas se pasa su registro de los
casos asintomáticos a los casos de
contagio y por eso pues cuando se
anuncian los casos diarios hay algunos
que pueden ser registrados de días
anteriores pero pues que se suman porque
la persona empezó a enfermarse por el
contagio del cob y eso que nos junta
años pero como es en el caso de las
muertes sucede algo relativamente
parecido y es que en general todos
contamos las muertes por la gente que
murió con kobe tigre contagiada de kobe
19 mientras que en china lo que se hace
es contar la gente que murió
exclusivamente por el cob y 19 por los
defectos de la neumonía y de las
complicaciones de la enfermedad de kobe
19 es decir no se cuentan si la persona
tenía por ejemplo otras condiciones
médicas que pudieran contribuir a eso
entonces se consideró la muerte por
diabetes eso se considera una muerte por
enfermedad cardiovascular no es eso hace
definitivamente que el registro sea más
bajo aunque es difícil saber en cuanto y
nos hace pensar en muchas cosas también
que hemos ido viendo en las redes y en
los medios en el caso de shanghái donde
mucha gente pues denunciaba que sus
adultos mayores habían muerto por
contagio de kobe 19 pero que no se había
registrado como tal porque pues quizás
lo que pasó fue que se agravaron sus
comorbilidades marc hay un subregistro
digamos porque estamos hablando de 4.000
muertos un poco más de 4.000 muertos
desde el inicio de la pandemia un número
un poco bajo para también tipo la
población china entonces quiero si hay
un exceso de muerte es real y creo que
influyen dos factores no por un lado
definitivamente las medidas chinas ha
hecho que la pandemia tenga un efecto
muy distinto en ese país y que
definitivamente las muertes sean mucho
más bajas que en comparación con otros
países que han tomado otro tipo de
decisiones pero un dato que sería clave
aquí tener y que pues en verdad no lo
tenemos al menos en dos años de
pandemias del tema del exceso de la
mortalidad que es todo esa mortalidad
que se compara entre el año pandémico y
el año no pandémico más allá de
registros oficiales de muertes contadas
11 por 19 entonces uno de los únicos
estudios que sí tuvo en cuenta este
exceso de mortalidad es un estudio
publicado en envíen jake que registra
los dos primeros meses de emergencia
sanitaria enojan y vemos hay una línea
amarilla que sube en el caso de la
mortalidad respecto a la línea azul que
es pues la mortalidad proyectada
efectivamente en esos dos primeros meses
hubo una diferencia alta de mortalidad
general en wuhan pero es que no sólo por
temas de kobe 19 también pasó con
enfermedades del corazón también pasó
con una mayor mortalidad por diabetes y
por último también suicidios y eso pues
para concluir con una reflexión no
también teniendo en cuenta lo que está
pasando en shanghai donde llevan a más
de un mes confinados vemos que las
cuarentenas también tienen efectos en
otras enfermedades y en la salud mental
de la población general marc usted ya
fue a la feria del libro de bogotá
todavía no este jueves es pero bueno y
le cuento que yo sí fui y junto al
equipo de producción de la matinal
directo américa de france 24 para hacer
una serie de entrevistas a
personalidades invitadas y pues hoy
vamos a comenzar entonces esta serie de
entrevistas así que les vamos a dejar
con una de las entrevistas que
preparamos para ustedes así que
disfruten por favor